[Music]
he's born in the United States I think
Riverside California reg will be calling
is that right riverside Riverside
California not internet reg has lakers
suns yeah that'll be at ten-thirty yeah
yeah hey I've been buying into the sun's
they're fun to watch it's a young team I
don't know if they're going to develop
into anything special I'm in early on
the Phoenix Suns reg and then tippy as
of late yet have you been seen some of
the little skirmishes and the little
scrapes that I'm kind of you know arose
from different games I kind of like the
chip eNOS but for you to say that you
were all in with the Lakers let it go
the Lakers were your team the
up-and-coming young team they still are
you are your business wall here well you
get a chance I gotta watch him ball
you're up you gotta wash your boat by
the way for your all international team
with Patrick Ewing Adric you endure a
little bit right bahamas jamaica jamaica
or bahamas one of the two right what he
v but i'm with you i'm starting my all
international team were cooking the
dream did he get any of your shots who's
that okie you can get all my shop yes
did he block any of yours he's like all
right I hear you blocked all my shots in
the middle his footwork was so good for
a big man you know I guess I thought a
came is underrated man I decide I think
he's so much fun to watch and the great
footwork he was just he was different I
thought he could have played a different
position if he was 63 I thought he could
have played nalini a lot of these big
guys if you if they were 63 didn't have
the talent level I thought Elijah one
would somehow been able to play in the
league he's on my all time you know
starting five team at power forward I
have curry med center okay um remember
you and I were having this discussion
about who's our small forward for so
many years
it was Larry Joe but remember how I kept
saying I've got to let it go yeah LeBron
was my three and obviously MJ is too and
magic is one so that's how much love and
respect I have for Hakim the dream and
you know what he's meant you say
underrated having played against them
there was nothing underrated about his
game I don't know need a nightmare I'm
nightmare or a dream or a dream during a
rocket fair Dirk goes for 30 grand last
night you know I I said that you you
can't write the history of the NBA
without mentioning that certain players
change the game Bill Russell I think
changed the game Michael have changed
the game I think Dirk Nowitzki changed
the game for big men coming in because
25 years ago Dirk is on the low post
Dirk Nowitzki changed for anybody who's
you know 68 and taller that you could be
a perimeter player and not only that the
floodgates really opened for
international players by looking at the
success of dirt and you know arguably
and I will say this he's probably the
best big man shooter the game has ever
seen certainly seven footer and the
skills that he possessed because he was
that inside outside threat if you look
at a lot of the international players
and look at our game today how so much
is predicated with having H stretch four
and a stretch five being able to knock
down threes you know be the trailer on a
break-in knocked down three that's all
because of Dirk no congratulations big
fella I mean having played against him
another one of those guys think about
the Golden Age of power forged during
that 90's and 2000's where you had Tim
Duncan Kevin Garnett you had Dirk you
had web I mean it was yet rachid Waller
and Tony only died I mean it was just an
unbelievable position to play back in
the day
it's dirt better than Larry Bird ah no
but I could see where people could love
to make the comparison it was totally
two different games I thought Larry was
a much better faster and probably
rebounder and dierks a better shooter
probably a better score though Larry had
his moment but I could see where people
can make the parallel and make the case
but if you're asking me personally my
opinion I'm going with Larry Joe do you
have in a bit ski story I do not okay I
do not I do not what it made for good
reason was offended you know can you
make a short one and make up one minute
and i'm meghan one sorry did you make
fun of his hair when he first came into
the league well what's funny is um
Charles and I were on a Nike why do have
a Dirk story Charles and I were on a
Nike tour and we were overseas claimed
in pain i believe and in germany for
this nike toros gary payton myself at in
case it kid sharif abdulraheem sir
charles myself and a few other nike guys
and we actually saw Dirk at i believe it
was 15 16 or 17 and I'm saying to myself
man this kid he was in the middle of the
between the free-throw Lane and
underneath the rim on his knees shooting
shots like at 15 or 16 um and just
wishing them in I'm like who is this kid
I mean laiki skinny uh but had the
follow-through and childhood like wall I
won't try to get him to go to auburn you
know what do you talk about like oh do I
get this kid to go to auburn I'm like
good luck is bad and the rest was
history so we saw Dirk at a very very
early agent I mean I've heard the name I
didn't know anything about it but when
he came over up like there's no way his
game is going to be able to translate
translate but 30,000 for Gator it has
translated people uh translate this form
Charles Barkley and Lonzo balls dad like
this getting personal between these two
that Charles fires back at lonzo's dad
to say let him just be a kid here and
then lonzo's dad talking about Charles
playing career didn't win a championship
wait where's it headed Wow once again
Charles is ruffling the feathers hand of
people but look Charles has a point
though because and I think we set this
on the show last week you got your you
already alonso has a bull's-eye on on
his back because he's that freshman
phenom okay we understand that freshman
probably player of the year he has UCLA
right number three the team is playing
well going into the pac-12 tournament
and or the tournament and now your dad
is coming out saying you're better than
you know the two-time MVP Steph Curry
even if you believe that my father has
every right to say that and believe that
but you're putting even a bigger and
higher expectations on your son where
you know there's guys that are you know
lacing up their shoes day what are you
kidding me I think that's the point
Charles is trying to say he didn't say
it as delicate as that but you know
Charles Charles he's gonna you know
speak from the hip and a lot and look
one of those dad is just sticking up for
a son and he truly if he truly believed
that that's great you're supposed to
have all the bleep like that in your son
but she got to be careful what you say
because there's a lot of bad boys out
there that would love to prove you wrong
okay but did your dad push you and
Cheryl yes absolutely but he wasn't
going in front of the media and the
camera saying I was better than Michael
Jordan right basically what it's a good
it's a good thing that he didn't do that
no thank you God Oh Russell Westbrook
jr. the third goes for 58 last night and
they lose I don't I don't know does that
strengthen his MVP candidacy or does it
weaken it a little bit then you get 58
and you don't win it weakens and for
weeks now I've been coming on your show
and you and I talked about this just
about every week who is the MVP between
hard
spirit because really it was a two-man
race for a long time now the door in my
opinion is wide open because you're
saying what are you talking about he's
still averaging a triple-double yes but
at some point in time we've got a factor
in the team success and to be the MVP
I'm just looking at Russell's last four
games he's lost in Portland and he lost
the Phoenix and he lost to dallas then
he lost again to Portland worst case
scenario you've got to win two of those
games to be the MVP you're playing the
bottom dwellers of each conference and
you've got to be able to win those games
you go oh and for against those teams
the numbers were phenomenal fantastic
but you look at quietly qilin ered what
he's done you look at what LeBron James
has done and you look at what James
Harden is done and their teams continue
to Lin I still have them as the
frontrunner to win the MVP because he's
doing something that has not been gunned
in 55 years to average a triple double
but we have to factor in team success as
well and right now the Thunder are
currently sitting seventh in the Western
Conference and on a four-game losing
streak against teams where you should
have at least been 500 over the last
four correct correct I I think our booth
and you cannot lose the Portland then
Phoenix then Dallas then Portland again
at home and you score 58 it loose on
again I want at least two of those games
I know that you had the lakers in the
sun's tomorrow night on TNT will you
bring up the dysfunction of the Lakers
front office and the attempted palace
coup there with jim buss and his
brothers against Jeannie absolutely you
have to I mean that's part of the Lakers
fabric that's that's one of the two meet
one of the big story lines along with
them hiring Rob palinka the new general
manager you've got to talk about magic
and you've got to talk about all that
that's part of the drama with the Lakers
and you know it's funny because I'm
going to rely on some of the old time
Showtime Laker great and I heard Michael
Cooper and I heard norm nixon both
talking and they said look back in our
day when we played Jeanie buss was the
one who was hanging around her father in
learning the business and by his side we
never saw any of the brothers so I'm
going to rely on the first hand guys
that were actually in it that small
genie that are on Team Jeannie so yeah
we gotta bring all that up that all
that's going to be on the table tomorrow
when we're discussing you know the
Lakers drama going forward what do they
do what does it mean to have an icon
like Andrew Johnson back in the mix and
you know what's it going to be like to
have Rob pálinka who was coby's agent
now being the general manager what does
that mean is going to be a lot like the
success of Bob Meyers who was a former
agent and now has had success you know
with the Warriors all that is going to
be in play tomorrow and another reason
why to tune in at the NBA and watch that
barn burner lakers vs. Sun ten thirty
eastern on tnt Reggie also has the
Mountain West men's tournament
championship game in Las Vegas coming up
as well theodore durkas of this year's
opinion to sri off around the corner
March Madness you've got spring training
this is the best time of the year
personally I got baseball I got
basketball or drama I've got my danette
I'm John seed or it doesn't get any
better safe travels wrench you look good
thanks buddy danette love y'all Reggie
Aloysius Miller the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience